i've got to be honest we can be
shallow af
[Music]
jubilee presents spectrum
season 5 episode 5 blind people
we invited six blind people to see the
range of their beliefs and experiences
hey i'm alicia and i'm 31 i live in
toronto currently
and i was diagnosed 10 years ago with
stargaze disease i'm christine ha
i'm in houston texas united states i'm
best known for winning masterchef season
three
hi i'm james rath i'm legally blind
since birth
and i'm currently in los angeles
california i'm lucy
edwards i'm 24 and i'm based in the
united kingdom
and i'm best known for being the first
ever blind presenter on bbc radio 1 and
i'm also a youtuber
i'm mario bonds i'm based in maryland i
am
best known from season two of the glee
project and
the pbs documentary blind love hi i'm
molly burke i'm 26 years old
in los angeles california i have
retinitis pigmentosa and i'm a youtuber
motivational speaker and commercial
model the first prompt is
being blind has enhanced my other senses
alicia somewhat agree
christine somewhat agree james
somewhat agree lucy disagree
mario strongly agree molly
agree a lot of
commenters say oh are you daredevil and
i think i just want to smash this
misconception
we don't have like supersonic other
senses yes
the misconception that we're somehow
superhuman that drives me nuts
but i think if i leave out of my house
and i've ordered an uber
i know my driveway right so when i walk
out of my house i'm totally blind but
immediately my ears
say okay there's the engine of the car i
hear the
incidental click of the doors unlocking
and i
instantly know where to reach out and
grab the door handle and of course to
the driver
they don't know a blind person just got
in there yeah
i said someone agree because it's more
so that i pay attention to things more
so i don't think necessarily that you
get heightened senses
it's more so that you have to depend on
your other four senses when you lose
your vision
i said i agree because
um i lost the majority of my vision at
14
i've been legally blind from birth and
when i lost my vision
i immediately struggled to adapt to my
other senses
i really struggled with taste i had to
eliminate things like garlic
onion spicy foods i also struggled with
smell a lot
i distinctly remember being in a
restaurant and they burnt cheese
and i had to leave the restaurant this
was the same year i went blind
so for me that was like a truly
immediate heightening
of my senses but things like my hearing
and my touch i would say are more based
on paying more attention
next prompt is i prefer to date
fellow blind people
alicia disagree christine
i disagree james disagree
lucy disagree mario disagree
molly somewhat disagree i've been told
that i'm a pretty beautiful man so i
need to have somebody keep telling me
that i still have myself together
it's important people don't know just
because we are blind doesn't mean that
we're automatically going to have a
blind partner we live in the freedom of
love coming in whatever
condition or situation it may be in i'm
currently married
to someone who is sighted and when i
think about him like life is easier
because he can drive me around
or tell me if like a certain ingredient
is expired in the pantry
or tell me if i have food in my teeth i
said
somewhat disagree um because i don't
prefer to date somebody
who is or who isn't i'm currently in a
relationship with a blind person
prior to this my partner has only dated
sighted women and i have only dated
sighted men
i don't care that neither of us can
drive because we can still get around
i don't care that he can't see some of
the things that i can't either
because we can find ways around that
like using apps like be my eyes
with my sighted partners in the past
there was only so much understanding
they could have
of my lived experience daily whereas
every day now
i get to come home to a partner that
completely understands my life
experience
me and ollie have a little bit of a
different sort of love story
i saw him before i went blind i went
blind two months into our relationship
so this may sound controversial but i
feel like he lived my blindness with me
he felt
all of the emotions that i felt as a 17
year old girl
feeling alone and having this loss and
grief
my sighted partner understands me
as lucy and understands me as a blind
woman
way deeper than i could ever
find in any blind partner just because
of what we've lived through together
so we're getting married next year so
yay
congratulations thank you i'd love to
ask a follow-up question too
people were curious are blind people
less
shallow about romantic partners oh
one of the first things i'm going to
notice is what does your voice sound
like
exactly hair is a massive thing for me i
love
when ollie has his hair cut i love his
beard i noticed
the feel of nice hands the same way a
sighted person would notice pretty eyes
smell smells definitely oh yeah
smell i get the sense of that feeling
clones gotta be right you know how like
girls are like are you into arms or abs
like i've always been like i'm an arms
girl because it's the first impression i
have of a man when he gives me a set of
god i'm like
but how's that arm hair situation how's
that arm fitness like
what's that like you know bicep like and
i get my full
scope of his you know his makeup and
there have been times where you know the
whole side of girl's like oh
she doesn't look like she belongs with
you but i did not care because it's what
i found to be attractive both by virtue
of personality and what she felt like to
me and everything like that was
was fine i am as shallow as my sighted
friends
it's just in different ways i do still
experience physical and sexual
attraction
like any sighted person would and so yes
i do
have preferences of height of hair
of body type well i would say the
opposite being legally blind
actually because i've been going through
the degeneration of my eye disease for
the last 10 years
like i was diagnosed when i was 21 and
back then i had different preferences
for what i was looking for and now my
preferences are more
lifelong like is this person going to
stay by me as my vision degenerates and
because of that i don't look so much at
what they look like because i can't see
them as well as i used to
but also because i need to know that
they match me inside
unsolicited help makes things harder
i would say somewhat agree i'm also
somewhat agree
strongly agree somewhat agree somewhat
agree
some would agree this happened the other
day at the mall and especially in a
post-pandemic world
uh i don't necessarily want people
getting up in my space
and it's hard to sort of police that as
a blind person sometimes
uh had a security guard just literally
take hold of me you didn't even know
where i was going then i told him and
then like i know where i am and i just
wasn't really comfortable with that
scenario and then i've had
past scenarios where i've actually been
literally guided into traffic
it was kind of a scary scenario and it
just all happened so fast i
really didn't know how to react i've
been in situations where i've actually
been cursed out for refusing help
i'll get the door for you oh no please
don't i have it i'll get the door for
you oh no i'm fine
i'm fine i have it i'll get the door for
you oh no i'm fine
damn i was just trying to help your
blind ass whoa it's almost like as if i
robbed them of a cub scout moment
but it's it's more of a respect thing i
totally agree with you mario i've got
google maps um
in my bone conducting headphones and i'm
with olga my guide dog
you know i know where i'm going there's
a lady who
stroked olga as i was crossing the road
there's cars coming
and you're just like wow like where am i
what am i doing then obviously olga's
distracted
then you're a bit off whack and i think
the motto
here should be just ask don't grab
just come up to me and say you know you
look lost i'm sally i'm a passerby
i was you know you you look like you
need help uh
do you need any assistance and then that
gives the autonomy back to us
and to say actually yeah i would really
love it or actually no
i don't need help right now so i chose
somewhat agree
for a different reason being as i don't
look
blind when i look at unsolicited help i
think of it as advice
they tend to give me advice like you
know maybe you just shouldn't work
because
this is too much work for you it doesn't
boost the morale it doesn't actually
help and it actually hinders and makes
me feel like
you don't see me as capable and
independent i
said somewhat agree i don't always
know that i need help so sometimes
unsolicited
advice or help is actually really
beneficial for me
but overwhelmingly i generally will ask
for help if i do need it
you know we have our process i might
have to sit through
you know three cycles of traffic at an
intersection if i've never crossed at
that intersection before
but i'm not lost i'm just doing what i
need to do
to be safe and to accommodate my
disability and i think all of us like to
have as much independence as much
freedom
as we can have and so sometimes
interrupting us having independence and
freedom
can be frustrating and it does feel like
you're underestimating our ability
i will say though that i appreciate it
if my husband tells me my cane's about
to go into dog poo
or something fair enough fair enough oh
yeah
that's not fun unwanted perfume
the city i live in is easily accessible
for me
somewhat disagree strongly disagree
somewhat disagree some will agree
strongly disagree
somewhat disagree i spent many years in
um
downtown los angeles which i love but
whenever people needed me to like
leave downtown to like go towards the
beach
side or go into the valley or you know
la's really big and spread out then it
requires
me to figure out okay can i combo this
between like
the metro and uber with like the cost of
and then considering the traffic
and that's why i'm actually in the
process of transitioning my life into a
more accessible city at the moment
la is not known for having good public
transit and it's also just very
expensive i usually have to
purely rely on uber and lyft i've chosen
to live
in a very walkable area of la which is
also very rare we have the
sidewalk braille the nice bumps on the
sidewalk all of the crossings near me
are either vibrating or tweeting so for
those reasons
yes my little area is accessible but la
as a whole
not not quite because of what molly and
james said i'm gonna flip from
somewhat disagree to someone agree being
that i live in toronto
there's a lot of things that i consider
blessings here but
there are things that i need that
haven't been
thought of because again a lot of times
when they're trying to
be accessible accessible is still an
ideology that doesn't encompass all of
us
like i love that when the buses come
there's audio announcements but
sometimes the drivers turn them off and
i've gone on the wrong bus and gone the
wrong way for half an hour and then had
to wander aimlessly
and because i can't see street signs i
don't know which way i'm going
yeah i'm somewhat agree as well where
i'm from in the uk
in london we don't have tweeting
crossings so that is so cool
we have a little cylinder at the bottom
that sort of moves and spins around so
we know when to cross but
i think london overall i'm really lucky
because i have the underground in the
underground it's all
audible overall black cabs are amazing
me and the cabbies have a good old chin
wag
they're ever so friendly so if you're
ever in london definitely get in a black
cab that is so sweet
i said strongly disagree i live in
houston
which is very much a commuter city there
are many parts of houston that have
either very
terrible sidewalks that need fixing that
are very crooked or they're low-hanging
branches
i feel like where there are a lot more
pedestrians it seems to be more
accessible
for those who are visually impaired
whereas like these wider spread cities
that depend a lot on
cars getting to get around like la or
houston seems to be less accessible
as a blind individual i end up paying a
fortune
when i want to be independent i end up
paying a fortune in transportation costs
um you know i look at it like this at
any time i want to leave the leave the
house
it costs me a coin so to speak
and not only is it often you know more
expensive to be blind because we do have
to pay higher rent
to live in these more accessible
neighborhoods and just ex accessible
technology and all of these extra
costs in our lives but also many blind
people live in poverty
um due to lack of job opportunities so
not only is it more expensive
you know we're lower income overall yeah
the huge point
you know 80 of working age blind adults
are unemployed and that's the statistics
that have risen steadily since the 1970s
so that's a really good point
i am offended when blind is used as one
of my descriptive characteristics
disagree disagree disagree
disagree disagree strongly disagree
i strongly disagree with this because i
think if i was to be offended
that means i'm ashamed and i'm not my
blindness is
is yes just a piece of me but it is a
large piece of me and it's a large piece
that has
informed many of the other pieces of me
so
call me blind because i am call me short
cause i am
call me pale because i am these are just
facts about me
um and they don't offend me they don't
upset me
they are things that i'm proud of and
that i wholeheartedly own
i do call myself the blind cook people
do know me as the blind chef
so that i do own that because that is a
huge part of who i am
but i wouldn't say i strongly disagree
because
i'm thinking of situations where i'm
introduced
at something and then people say like
she's a chef oh but she's also
blind isn't that even more amazing i
don't want to be
put on this other pedestal in spite of
my vision loss yeah it's interesting
because i
i i'm with christine that where it's a
disagree i do
love it that in the bio the bio
blindness is the last thing on the list
i'm you know mario bonds 32 year old
singer songwriter from maryland
and then you can add he lost his sight
to morning gory syndrome at blah blah
blah
it's done in a respectable way i didn't
say strongly disagree because
i think being diagnosed at 21 a lot of
who i am
was still being a sighted person up
until 21 and because of that i have to
honor that
it's really important that we're all
that out there
shouting about the blind message that
we're united and we're owning it because
for ages i didn't want to be blind i
went blind at 17
and i didn't like the word i lost my
vision and i don't know what to do
and i'm grieving and there's a loss
there and you know
what are these connotations of this word
blind it's scary you know
i was that girl at school that didn't
want to use her cane and didn't want to
own it because there is still a lot of
people out there that see the tagline
blind
and go oh and you know it got a lot
easier
when i owned my mobility aid and said
right i am coming out as blind
to the world and in turn i'm coming out
as myself i'm liberated i'm free
and this is me and it just felt like you
were breathing a sigh of relief
being blind has affected my mental
health
strongly agree strongly agree some would
disagree
strongly agree strongly agree strongly
agree
so having been born legally blind i
never
knew anything different it wasn't until
like kids become more aware and stuff
and
poke out differences and really nag on
those that
that's when i really had that whole
journey of uh
my mental health and then being
diagnosed with mental illnesses and
stuff but that really i i don't blame my
blindness i
blame the individuals that may have
really resulted in in
my mental health deteriorating and it
wasn't actually until
uh so i got like a surgery it was
experimental
i did regain vision um for the first
time and was considered just visually
impaired
on the mark and that only lasted for
about two years and then overnight it
all just
deteriorated went back to how it was and
um but i didn't find happiness until
after i went blind again
um i think it was just because this is
how i'm supposed to experience life
because i feel like there's a greater
purpose for it
uh in my life and i gotta do something
with that james i appreciate what you
said
i thought that was quite powerful
because i hadn't thought of it
like that before being a person who has
been in several situations where i was
taken advantage of
um whether it was by a family member
whether it was
you know a teacher molesting me as a
teenager or even just more recently
whether it's kids being kids and kids
trying to you know kind of get over on
their blind parent
um of course i'm on it now but all of
those things
you know kind of bleed into into one
principle theme
that we are blind um and and sometimes
you're you're gonna go to those
emotional corners where i resent being
blind because
of you know what people might do to
you know weaponize my circumstance um
so you know james you really said
something that stuck with me there
mario i appreciate how you phrased
all that and shared all that it's hard
isn't it it's one of those things where
you look back and you think wow
why me i guess that's what i did at the
start i was
with my tub of ben and jerry's um in my
bed
yeah yeah and i i was that girl i was
the only girl
in my family in my friendship group
everyone cited
me wishing she had a sight back and you
know
my organ died in front of my eyes like
of course i'm gonna feel
low you know what i mean it is a
grieving process it's definitely not
just vision loss it's a loss of losing a
sense of self as well it's a loss of
having hopes and desires for future that
might not be
what it is it might be better but it
won't be what you envisioned it to be
originally
blind people are three times more likely
to deal with depression and anxiety
so if you are blind and you struggle
with mental illness
you don't have to feel alone we
statistically are more susceptible to
struggling with it and to me it makes
sense ultimately we're living in a world
that isn't designed or created for us
and we're making our way and we're doing
it and we're killing it
but it does make life in certain certain
circumstances more difficult
i have experienced discrimination
somewhat agree
strongly agree strongly agree strongly
agree
strongly agree strongly agree
oh i was the only one that said somewhat
eh
i wonder if the difference is is given
we all use mobility aids um
no actually there's this
intersectionality between
living my entire life as a black woman
and
being as i've only been diagnosed with
this eye disease and lived with it for
the last 10 years i can see
a clear difference between the
discrimination of being black
versus the discrimination of being blind
when i tell people that i've gone
through something or
faced discrimination as a black female
sometimes
i'm met with doubt or kind of like
pushing it to the side or it's in your
head
or it's not that bad whereas i feel like
people meet me
halfway when it comes to my vision loss
people find it admirable
and kind of attached to identity as
inspirational it's a different energy
it's a different temperature which is
why i said
somewhat not strongly as a blind black
man i can say that i've
experienced discrimination on both
fronts unfortunately
you know the crux of me is really the
arts i did try out for american idol
there's several rounds of auditions you
have to go through to get on these
reality shows and this is like the first
level of it
there at my guitar and i sing my heart
out
and then the producer he stopped me and
said dude
normally we really don't let blind
people through
and even if we do we don't usually let
them go so far because
they can be so difficult to deal with
during production but man you're so dope
i gotta say yes
is that supposed to be a compliment that
type of stuff really can leave you
feeling unaccomplished because obviously
you want to be seen for your ability
you want to be seen for the content of
your character but unfortunately that
doesn't always happen
and and that can you know a bigger plug
to earlier conversation we had
that can sometimes be a catalyst for a
plunge into
you know momentary depression as well i
do feel like
like the bulk of the discrimination that
i face is due to my guide dog
and it's only getting increasingly worse
as the the misuse of
service dogs and the use of fake service
dogs increases
i've been a guide dog user for 13 years
now and
over the last five year over year it
gets worse and worse and worse
and i face more and more and more
discrimination i strongly agree
when i'm entering a taxi people see
my guide dog and not the person who
needs a ride
i've had someone spit at me and tell and
swear
at me um and you know even though now i
found great taxi drivers
in central london um it still does scare
me
with the job related stuff uh i've been
in those interviews um everything seems
to go well
they're giving me an estimation of like
when i'm going to hear back
oh to me next tuesday yeah we even want
you to maybe even
head this department and then when you
start mentioning accommodations then the
conversation sort of shifts and then
next thing i know i get an automated
you know decline like through email 30
days later
instead of hearing back on that tuesday
often times people come
approach and you know want to ask to
take a photo
they'll always ask my husband like is it
okay if i take a photo with christine
there's just things like that that i
think a lot of people don't think about
i feel like
when someone asks somebody else if they
are allowed to take a photo with me
that i'm a lesser person that you know i
cannot make my own independent decision
i know it's a cited world but i always
find it amazing that because of the
preconceived notion of what they think
blind people
should look like or shouldn't look like
that albeit i think it's ridiculous
that i i even get things like you know
there's no way this guy is blind he's
muscular and it's like what
what are you saying yeah blindness is
quite
rare and i think the main place that
people get
their their opinion on what blindness
must be like is through
entertainment because i choose to put
myself out there online
and i don't quote look blind
or look the way people think i'm
supposed to as a disabled woman
i get a lot of she's faking it you know
this whole reddit threads there's whole
blogs devoted to trying to debunk my
blindness
and that's why representation is so
important and that's why videos like
this one
is so important to watch to share
because we need the education to spread
so that that ignorance is
um is combated with education
if i could regain my sight with a cure i
would want to
strongly agree somewhat agree
strongly disagree disagree strongly
agree
disagree if i was to get my sight back i
would love to see the faces of the
children that i've adopted that would be
amazing
i said disagree and my answer probably
a good four years ago would have been
the complete opposite
i'm going to have my wedding next year
and there's so much of me
that wants to see ollie's face when i'm
walking down the aisle
or my mom's face or my sister's face or
my dad's face again
because they have now faded from my
memory
that does hurt me inside quite deeply
and
just thinking of the milestones really
in life and
having kids with ollie in the future but
i think
the reason that my answer is disagree is
because i have finally come to accept
who i am
and the fact that i really do deeply
believe
now that life without sight is truly
beautiful when i embrace that
that's when i don't want my sight back i
don't need it to feel fulfilled and to
feel that you see
i said disagree like lucy for many of
the same reasons
um at the beginning of my vision loss
i dealt with a lot of anger resentment i
threw myself pity parties asked why me
all i wanted was my sight back in fact i
was literally
the youth ambassador for charity whose
sole purpose was to fundraise to find a
cure for my disease
and along my self-acceptance and
self-love journey
i realized how toxic that mindset was
for me and that's where the social model
versus medical model comes in the
medical model
is the idea that the answer to
disability
is curing it um which puts
really the onus on the disabled person
we are the burden on society and we need
to change
be fixed be healed in order to be whole
or good enough or fit into society
whereas the social model of disability
says actually the disabled person is
perfectly fine
and they aren't the problem at all the
real problem is society's
inaccessibility with our infrastructure
in terms of
you know the design of our buildings and
our physical space around us
but also our technology and just
everything we use and interact with on a
daily basis
so for all of those reasons i don't want
to cure so
have gone through a bit of a process of
trying to cure
my sight back when i was about 11 years
old feeling pressured to do so
in order to fit in and it reverting back
within two years
i was never happy during those two years
because i wasn't doing it for me it
really didn't feel like i was myself
until i was able to
really embrace my blindness one in seven
people in the world have some form of
disability
and that may only increase as time goes
on i know for me and the purpose that
i'm
here on this earth to do it's to leave
this world a more accessible and
accepting place uh than i found it i
answered
somewhat agree ideally i think i would
want my vision back for like
maybe a couple days just so i can watch
some foreign films see what
you know maybe my friends and family
look like now
but then i feel like i don't necessarily
want my full vision back
forever because i think i'm kind of at
the halfway point in my life where i've
lived half of my life with vision and
half of it without
so it would be so different and
difficult
and i think losing my vision put me in a
position where
i was forced to think outside of the box
and create opportunities for myself and
be more
courageous but it would be kind of cool
just to see what cars look like nowadays
i've come more into myself and kind of
like what christine said there's a lot
about all of our characters that
couldn't have been wouldn't have been
had it not been
the challenges of losing our vision i
feel like i could take the last 10 years
in the character development and take
that forward
whether i'm visually impaired or sighted
yeah i don't think i would be the person
i am today if i hadn't lost my vision
but past that you know i really
work hard to be the coolest blind dad
ever
my kids don't miss the beat i'm able to
chase
and play with my seven and ten year old
um
i box with my team my teenagers they
think i'm superman because
they see me work out all the time and we
play and we do this and we do that
i'm content just being um
super blind mario i don't know about any
of you but sometimes
when i think about who i would be if i
was sighted like it scares me i'm like i
don't
know who that person would be and i'm so
happy with this person
that i'm like i don't want to see who
she would be this person's good
yeah yeah i don't need to think about
that girl i wholeheartedly
respect everyone's journey and and
everyone's perspective
yeah definitely blindness is a spectrum
and we're all so unique
this was great you guys this is an
amazing bunch i'm so honored to meet
everybody and
and just perspectives yeah such a
beautiful experience i love hearing from
you guys
thanks for thanks for all of you it's so
nice meeting all of you
i hope we can all stay in touch yeah
sounds good it was nice talking
everybody bye
i'm gonna go to bed now guys good night
take care everyone stay
safe